going to be at Howen and
Catalina it's a blue Ford truck
displaying some kind of sov Citizen
looking tag can you start us a second
please
says post the union
treaty G convention neutral neutral zone
transport vehicle that's not how this
works
man you know what the flag upside down
means no it's it's a a sign of
distress hey boss how you doing not too
bad D the sheriff's
office I just got pulled over hey so the
reason why I'm stopping you Boss I
didn't recognize the tagging was on your
vehicle yeah okay you your J regation
with you here you go I got the paperwork
right here where's the paperwork at
Melle
seat right it's where behind
seat it's on
[Music]
speaker okay where's your driver's
license
boss no I don't need my window now I'm
sorry so do you have a driver's license
yeah right there okay what's your name
boss I don't see your name on here can
you point it to
me okay that's not how this works
where's your uh
name I just didn't hear the
[Music]
paperwork okay here you talk to
now ma'am if he refuses to identify
himself in this traffic stop is going to
be an issue sir uh-huh he
[Music]
Iden you
know that remes him from your jur uh I
it doesn't matter who he identifies as
he's operating a motor vehicle in the
State of Florida
[Music]
ma'am
yeah
4 how far my second
no I just want checking ma'am so this is
what this is what's going on the the tag
on his vehicle does not appear like it's
it's proper back to any state so appears
the vehicle is unregistered then on top
of that I come up here I'm asking for
his identification documents and he's
handing me a stack of papers instead of
a driver's license so I'm concerned he
might be driving without a driver's
license and his vehicle might be
unregistered yeah okay where's your
what's your name
boss sir what's your name right here can
I see your name please right here where
right who point it right there where
where's what's where's your name sir I
don't are you the postmaster that's what
it says postmaster I am the postm which
so is your first name Mark or your last
name Mark no so nothing on here has your
name right there your destiny Mark death
is that how am I saying it and what's
your last name boss I can't see it right
there W werman what's your date of birth
sir it's all right there it's not I'm
not telling me anything all right well
this is the thing if we cannot properly
identify you then it could be a
potential issue for us coming up I'm
tell you that you cannot to us
uh well that's fine he doesn't
necessarily have to talk to me but he
does have to obey my lawful
commands
gen hey Murphy why is he looking at my C
this is part of his job hey Murphy can
you just switch to me real
fast
who Lieutenant who treat what what
Lieutenant who auth Lieutenant
who
lieen I think you me trying to say Gara
yeah just hold on here I just got to
look at something real fast
[Music]
yes 10 form that's going to be negative
comes back on a blue 2012 for registered
to a
Lin the B out of Lake hel expired back
in
2022 all right sir this is kind of where
we're at so I checked the uh hang on
hang on Michelle hang on hang on hang on
Michelle Michelle hang on so this is
kind of where we're at so I checked the
VIN the car is currently looks like it's
unregistered so if you don't have do you
have a Florida driver's license or
driver's license out of another state
that I can check to ensure that you're a
LIC driver right there's all I got okay
well there's a problem so I tried to
search you up under this I can't find
anybody you know I can't find you so if
I can't verify that you're you have a
valid driver's license then how am I
supposed to let you drive off she's
coming all that's not going to that's
not going to change anything he's saying
I got to have a valid driver license top
rated motor vehicle in state of Florida
yes sir
okay
Cina yeah okay sir it's a it's a simple
question do you have a valid driver
there death your middle
name well because he's got it right here
he's got the paperwork in his hand all
we're trying to do is just identify it's
it and then send you on your way um is
that your last name y okay is your ID
through Florida no what state is it
from I'm right here yeah what state is
it from yeah she's coming that's fun
what state did your ID from I don't have
an ID I would surrender my ID my birth
and everything when you used to have an
ID what state was it from um Colorado
Colorado okay what's your what's that it
don't it don't it won't rest it because
here right there that's fine I don't
need her actually and she's not going to
come over here um what is your date of
birth it's right there everything's
right there no not everything is right
here okay does that make sense all this
I
know I'm not why why do I need to get
out have I done something wrong whoa
whoa whoa whoa before you drag me out of
the car what have I done hop out of the
car I've done something wrong you're
failing to re you're failing to identify
yourself that's not a that's not a lot
that's not a Mis Mariner not a lot hey
don't get in my car what are you guys
doing watch this we're joking out of the
fucking car get out go getting me out
the car all right all right I'm getting
out all right I'm getting out you guys
are jerking me around you guys are
jerking me around look I got you all
right I'm not jerking
around under
D
[Music]
youer SP my show my ID
not you tell me not an ID state separ
your Fe not stay here and I don't I
don't go for SE stop talking on me
please it's not registered stay on my
wallet it's not stay on my wall
everything's coming out your
pocket I don't I don't accept you might
not accept it but it doesn't mean it's
not happening you guys are IL legally
fucking searching me for no fucking
reason at all
none none stop yelling
you just
okay yes do you want to talk to him or
not if not we're going to get him out of
here we're trying to give you the
keys hey what hey back you calling
myself because I have a phone number for
him unlock this door now no I'm not
going to un you get out we breaking open
the door now yes so now get out get out
get out
oh
[Laughter]
shit 241 and you're fucking hurting me
your us
no I'm not looking
in not x
9 we have another 1050
we
[Music]
have is anybody else cover in
blood who's got a who's got app